-It is great to see you, buddy,
and thank you
for playing Password.
-So much fun.
-I appreciate that.
It's been a while since you --
since you've been on the show.
-I know, yeah.
It's been a long time.
-Yeah, we always
have a good time.
-Yeah. But, you know,
I've been watching the show.
I love the show, and --
-Appreciate that.
-So tonight -- I haven't
been here in a long time,
and I just wanted
to show you my appreciation.
So I brought a gift.
-You don't have to do that.
-No, but I thought it's kind of
like a gesture, so --
Because I watch the show
and I love everything you do.
I love all the taped segments
and the live segments,
like what you did tonight,
so I thought I would
just present the show --
This is for the show.
It's not for you personally.
-Okay.
-It's for the production,
but it's a check for, you know,
$1,400 and a little more --
$1,433.
[ Light laughter ]
-Wow. This is --
-And I need to explain, maybe,
just the amount.
-This is $1,433
to "The Tonight Show."
-To "The Jimmy Fallon Show,"
actually.
-Oh, yeah, well, you can --
we can change that, but, uh...
-That's very sweet of you.
This is --
-I just -- I thought --
-Why that amount?
-I was talking to
my business accountant.
He said this is kind of
what I can afford right now.
But the other --
-A scrape.
-Well, and I thought when
you're expecting nothing,
It's kinda like --
-Wow.
-I mean, obviously
it's all relative, you know.
-No, this is a --
-Some people might
donate more, but --
-$1,433. No.
-The thing is, you're going to
get hammered on taxes
when you take this, so, like,
it's gonna end up being
kind of like $750 that you net.
And that's why I aimed it
for this -- for this figure.
-This is unbelievable.
This is so thoughtful.
I think you might be
the first person ever...
-Well, that's what I thought.
-...donate money
to "The Tonight Show."
-It's a nice thing to do.
You can use it
for production costs,
which is what's written here,
"For production."
-Yes, "For production."
This is so sweet of you.
-Rent some nice costumes
or something
and do, like, a funny sketch.
I don't know.
-I don't know
what to do with this.
But we're going to
do something with it.
-You can frame it if you want,
put it in your office.
But the thing is, this is worth
so much more than $1,433,
because if you have, like,
someone like Mark Cuban
on the show,
which I'm sure you've had...
-Yeah.
-...you know, Mark Cuban
has like $2 billion, I believe.
-Yeah, that's correct.
-And so, you know --
-He's watching.
-A million dollars is like
a thousand dollars, you know,
for you and me to Mark --
I mean, how much money
do you have?
[ Laughter ]
I mean, but for me, like,
you know, like, he has so much,
and he'll see this and he'll
see, like, the, you know --
You'll put this on YouTube, and,
like, he'll see the comments.
Everyone will be like, "Wow,
Michael's this fantastic guy."
-Yeah.
-And he'll be like...
-"I want to be a fantastic guy."
-..."I want to do it,"
and he'll bring you --
-Mark Cuban.
-Who knows what kind of check
he'll cut?
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This is smart.
That is so smart.
-Well, the last thing
to say about it
is that it's not, like,
actually a check.
It's a deposit slip.
But that's only because --
I talked to a guy, and he said,
"Don't put --
They'll will see your
account number on TV.
Don't do that."
So this is largely symbolic.
And, like, I'll Venmo --
[ Laughter ]
You know,
we'll figure it out later.
Whatever.
We'll figure it out later.
-This is a symbolic gift.
-Well, that's what --
When they do the big checks,
it's not a real check.
It's a symbol.
-So it's similar
to a giant cardboard check.
It's this.
I appreciate it.
-And that's how I show love.
So, if it's not good enough,
then whatever.
-No!
No, of course.
Oh, my gosh, nothing but love.
Michael Cera.
[ Applause ]
Thank you very much.
[ Laughter ]
-You want me to hold it, too?
-Yeah, you hold it there.
-Hey, I-I know -- I just want
to say congratulations.
Since I've seen you,
you've become a dad.
-Yes.
-How's fatherhood?
Congratulations, buddy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're an amazing dad.
Are you loving it?
How old's baby?
-He's 11 months old.
-Wow.
-He's almost one.
-Yeah, saying words?
-No, he kind of, like,
grasps at making sounds.
Like, he has said "dada,"
but I kind of don't have, like,
enough points on the graph yet
to know if he actually knows
what he's saying when he says it
or if he's just making sounds.
-Doesn't matter. It counts.
-But it feels good.
[ Laughter ]
-If it sounds like "Dada,"
just have it be Dada, yeah.
-Yeah, and I just -- I love him.
And I know he'll
be watching this someday
and just be so proud of me,
how well I did tonight
and everything.
[ Laughter ]
-He will.
He will see the love.
It's just --
That's symbolic, you know.
-I love him.
-How much love --
-I love you, son.
-Now, I want to
talk about this movie,
'cause this is for children.
-This is "Paws of Fury:
The Legend of Hank."
-Yes.
-I love the name.
I love "Paws of Fury:
The Legend of Hank."
But then I also was doing
a little research on this.
It's produced by Mel Brooks.
-Mel Brooks.
-Who's one of my comedy heroes.
-Me too.
-And he does a voice, as well?
-He's so funny in it.
-Did you meet Mel Brooks?
-You know, I never met him
in relation to this project,
but I actually met him, like,
years ago
just randomly when I was --
I was working
on the Culver City lot.
And he has an office there,
and I was with my friend.
He said, "Why don't we
just go say hi to Mel?"
And so we went over,
and he had us in his office
for like an hour.
-He was just there?
-Yeah, and he was happy
to have us.
The first thing he said to me,
he went,
"Hey, thanks for saving Juno."
[ Laughter ]
I didn't know what he meant.
I didn't know if he meant,
"Thanks for saving the movie."
-Yeah.
-Like I was the saving grace.
Or "Thanks for saving
the character,"
which doesn't make any sense.
-No, but doesn't matter.
-I think he was just reaching
for anything to say
and he maybe didn't remember
the specifics of the movie.
-I'll take it.
-So I said, "What do you mean?"
And I shouldn't have said that.
I think I've learned since then,
just say, "Thanks, Mel,"
and high-five
and just be friends
and don't create a weird --
-Don't question it, yeah.
-Yeah, move forward.
You must have learned this.
-Did you move on after that.
-Yeah, we powered through it.
Yeah, he kind of, you know,
shrugged it off.
And we recovered
and had a good time.
-Yeah, I mean, that's kind of
a great memory of Mel Brooks.
You go in, you have weird
small talk, and then you leave.
-And then he signed
all these box sets for us.
He was like, "Here,
take this, take this."
-He signed you --
-Yes.
And actually he didn't even
have his new one on him.
He's like, "I would love
to give you my new one."
He didn't have it,
and then we were walking out,
and he was, like, running across
the parking lot at us --
"I found one, I found one,
I found one."
-Mel Brooks
is running after you?
-No, he was great.
-I love this.
-He's an amazing guy,
and, you know, meeting him
was incredible.
He's, like,
a total hero of mine.
-Do you like doing
animated films?
-It's great, it's great.
It's actually, you know, like,
really hard work.
Like, you kind of feel
physically exhausted after it.
More so than, you know, being on
set for like a 12-hour day even.
-Really?
-Because they just kind of --
Well, especially this one
when I'm playing a dog, Hank.
And -- Like, from the title.
"Legend of Hank."
-Yeah. You are hank.
-I am Hank.
-It's you speaking
into a microphone.
-Yeah.
-And you're exhausted by it.
-Well, okay.
Not the whole thing.
But, like, sometimes they say --
You know, there's, like,
action sequences in this movie.
They go, "Okay,
now we just need you --
Michael, we need, like, a bank
of exertion noises
or, like, doggy panting."
So you just stand there at
the mic for a half hour going
[Grunting]
And you're doing that
for a half-hour.
-Okay.
-And by the end of it,
you're like, "Guys, I --
we need to stop."
Like, "I can't --"
-"I'm gonna pass out."
-You're hyperventilating.
-Yeah, I gave
as much as I can give.
What more do you want?
-Yes.
-What do you want?
-It ain't for wimps.
-$1,433? Come on.
I'm giving you grunts here
and pants like a dog, yeah.
It's super cute.
It's super fun.
It's action-packed.
-Yeah.
-The idea is that Hank
wants to be a samurai.
-Yes.
-It's not easy.
-No.
-No, so this is --
Yeah, this is "Paws of Fury:
The Legend of Hank."
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Michael Cera.
Check it out.
-What's that?
-The blindfold
is to help you focus.
-Ah.
-Now listen.
Tell me what you hear.
-I hear you talking and moving.
-Good.
[ Bird squawks ]
-I hear a bird.
-That's it.
-I smell flowers, actually.
-Dogs have a keen sense of smell
and excellent hearing.
-I hear a dragonfly.
[ Buzzing ]
[ Sniffing ]
I smell wood burning.
[ Kettle whistling ]
Smell tea brewing.
[ Sniffing ]
Hey, are you making nachos?
'Cause someone
just cut the cheese.
-Lesson over.
Well done.
-Yeah, it is well done.
That's how you do it
right there.
Michael Cera, everybody.
I love having you on.
"Paws of Fury: The Legend
of Hank" is in theaters now.
We'll be right back
with Keke Palmer, everyone.
Stick around.